welcome back to the show I am Jesse
dollar more standing in sitting in
actually as you can see sitting in for
David backman while he is away listen
over the course of the of the the first
few days of the year when Congress was
coming in and the new majority of
Republicans took over we witnessed the
absolute debacle that was the election
of of Kevin McCarthy as Speaker of the
House the 15 votes that it took the day
upon day upon day of trying to find out
who was going to be Speaker of the House
of Representatives and Matt Gates led
the effort Matt Gates and Lauren bobert
and Chip Roy there was a few bad actors
uh although it is kind of a lesson in
the enemy of my enemy can also be my
friend even though they're certainly not
friends it was all chaotic and you know
kind of entertaining to watch a lot of
people will say that oh is bad for the
institution and all of that and I don't
really take part in all of that the the
more disorganized they are the better it
is for the country because the little
damage they're able to do
but Matt Gates was one of these ring
leaders here in this and
um Ari melber I don't know why but Ari
melber had Matt Gates on his show to
talk about this and they spent a lot of
time and this is the reason listen I'm
not going to say be so critical that I
would say you shouldn't have him on your
show but what good does it do you're not
going to get to the truth if you ask him
questions Matt Gates is going to
systematically lie to you right to your
face over and over and over in classic
Matt Gates Republican fashion so I don't
understand it but he was there and we
need to talk about it he was asked
specifically about what secret deal was
made with McCarthy to actually get him
the votes to become speaker there's
obviously a mini page 40 page document
outlining the rules and going forward
some of the the procedures that will
govern this particular Congress but
there was also like a three or four page
document that's in secret that no one
knows the contents of of exactly what
was negotiated and this is important for
a number of different reasons one mainly
because of the hypocrisy of the
Republican party and this particular
flavor of Republican that acts like
transparency in government is what we
should be going for when in actuality
they're not interested in that at all
watch this appearance by Matt Gates on
MSNBC so you mentioned Personnel that is
something that has been reportedly
written down and agreed to on the side a
sort of a side deal here's congresswoman
mace on some of that
you don't know what they got or didn't
get we haven't seen it we don't have any
idea what promises were made or what
gentlemen's handshakes were made
let's get into this maybe we resolved it
once and for all right here on live TV
uh you have a 55-page rules package that
part is public under the rules we could
put up reporting on that we all know
about that then you have reporting of a
secret three-page agreement reading here
from Punchbowl McCarthy and his allies
hash this out with the freedom caucus
it's got the other concessions including
rules committee that's Personnel I
believe what you just referred to and
other things
Point Blank Congressman have you or your
staff seen this additional agreement in
writing in any form
yeah it took multiple forms there was
specifically a side-by-side sheet where
we made offers to McCarthy there were
some offers he accepted some he modified
some he rejected just like you'd see in
any negotiation I could tell you that
Thomas Massey chip Roy Ralph Norman
being on the rules committee would not
have happened but for this negotiation
folks like representative Clyde
representative cloud two great
conservatives on the Appropriations
Committee that's a direct result of
these negotiations this week we'll be
voting on Paul gosar's legislation to
end the covid National Emergency that
was a piece of policy the McCarthy kind
of I'll let you continue but the
question where I'm going is why keep
that secret
I'm what are your questions I'm happy to
tell you any element I'm actually quite
proud of the work product so it's no
secret at all the product though I I
appreciate you here taking questions but
why not release the written product that
exists and it's currently been kept
secret and for context uh you and others
have talked about bringing transparency
to government it's one thing to hear it
described and another thing for the
government now the the house Republican
majority to just release whatever this
underlying material is here's a little
bit of how you and some others have
sounded about government secrecy
the American people are tired of the
swamp games we had the audacity to want
to know what in the world was going on
behind closed doors why not commit to
releasing the written agreement or
working to get it released tonight
yeah I have no objection to that that's
what I'm talking about there's no
answers there well we agreed to some
things some things were agreed to other
things were not agreed to well there you
go all transparent
I don't know that it there was any
efficacy that nothing was gained from
this other than yeah he's a liar and we
know he's a liar
um
what we do know though is that Kevin
McCarthy did make a deal
and as a result of that deal some of
those names that he mentioned and he
rattled off very quickly they're some of
the most radical in the Congress Thomas
Massey him and his family taking
pictures with their AR-15s uh Lauren
bober
on on very important committees on the
house uh oversight and accountability
committee Paul gosar is on that
committee Marjorie Taylor green is on
that committee not only is Marjorie
Taylor green on that committee she's on
Homeland Security
she's on the covet Origins committee it
all of this should bring alarm bells
ringing in your head about what kind of
dirty dark room back room deals Kevin
McCarthy made with these Maniacs Andrew
Clyde
the man who said that the Insurrection
against the United States of America
which is like a normal tourist visit
chip Roy Ted Cruz is former Chief of
Staff
this is where we are in our Congress
this is our Congress they act like they
want to get so much things done yet
they're all they're going to be doing is
focused on investigations they're not
going to work with the Biden
Administration to pass anything useful
or reasonable for the American people
because that's not on the agenda owning
the libs is on the agenda cruelty is on
the agenda
because they know look they'll they're
going to pass bills and brag about the
bills they passed that are going to be
radical in nature that have no chance of
even getting through the Senate
not to mention getting to the
president's desk for a signature we need
to play for them the I'm Just a Bill
yeah I'm only a bill that The
Schoolhouse Rock
to re-educate them on how a bill is made
that their role as legislators
is to write and pass legislation for the
express purpose of getting to the
president's desk for signature
instead this is what we get
very disheartening one of our sponsors
today is mosh whether you're at the gym
on the go between meals mosh protein
bars are the smart snack to keep your
body and brain fueled there's six
delicious flavors like blueberry almond
crunch peanut butter chocolate Crunch
cookie dough crunch each mosh bar comes
packed with 12 grams of protein 6 grams
of fiber but also important nutrients
like vitamin B vitamin D
Omega-3s and only one gram of sugar and
160 calories I've tried tons of
different protein bars really you can't
beat the taste and the texture of mosh I
love these my favorite is the chocolate
Crunch simple satisfying now that I'm
back in the gym I'll snack on one of
these after a workout mosh is also a
mission-driven company with a portion of
all proceeds donated to support women's
is brain health research through the
women's Alzheimer's movement at
Cleveland Clinic mosh is giving my
audience 20 off plus free shipping on
your first six count trial pack go to
moshlife.com Pacman the link is down
below